[Musique]
le fait que les femmes travaillent ce
que vous êtes pour
bah oui ça leur donne une certaine
impression d'égalité avec l'homme que
pensez-vous des femmes qui travaillent à
bien les femmes qui travaillent chez son
besoin de chapour et des ménages
d'accord mais une fois que la sienne
c'est aussi bien il est assez difficile
de conjuguer
un poste de cadre
deux responsabilités donc intéressant il
s'avère avec une vie privée
oui c'est pas une mauvaise idée ça
rapporte de l'argent marie et ça soulage
un peu là les maisons c'est pas mauvais
je pensais qu'il pouvait pas avoir un
scellé comme le vôtre par exemple
pourquoi je sais pas moi différences de
sexe c'est pas parce que penser des
femmes qui travaillent c'est bien mais
enfin
ça prend un peu d amour quoi que pensez
vous du travail féminin 90 elle devait
travailler pour pouvoir travailler parce
qu'il y en a des choses à la fois on
peut pas nous faire le travail et la
menace je pense que c'est normal ça
passe mais faut que ce soit les métiers
qu'ils soient appropriés quoi la place
des femmes c'est au foyer ne sais pas où
travaille le mari devant initialement
d'argent pour qu'une femme puisse à ce
que vous voyez que le foyer plus vivre
correctement
c'est pas une mauvaise chose il faut les
occuper parce que s'ils restent à la
maison
1 après ça court que pensez-vous des
femmes qui travaillent
je suis pas d'accord je vais faire la
femme à la maison et je travaille
pourquoi parce que quand je me suis tout
près son linge 100 lits sa cuisine ses
enfants et s'occupe de tout le monde
[Musique]